ha sido un símbolo internacional tanto
por su pericia como por el hecho de ser
uno de los primeros jugadores negros del
mundo hay que recordar que Pelé se muere
con 82 años y Él llega a ser un jugador
de renombre en un Brasil que hacía poco
más de medio siglo que había eliminado
la esclavitud y al principio él tuvo
mucho muy presente en su vida este ese
tema de hecho Apple se le ha reprochado
muchas veces de no ser una persona
política de no haber condenado
públicamente La dictadura para algunos
la explicación es que él siempre supo
que estaba despuntando en un mundo muy
difícil un deporte pensado para los
blancos la imagen de Pelé en el maracaná
junto a la reina de Inglaterra recién
fallecida también se ha recuperado hace
poco tiempo porque no era usual que un
Monarca estuviese al lado de un jugador
negro en un mundo donde la diferencia
racial todavía era muy presente Pelé
consiguió gracias a su maestría a su
arte a los bonitos superar unas barreras
que para la época serían impensables Hoy
vemos las nacionales de fútbol de países
como Francia y hay muchos jugadores
afrodescendientes pero en aquella época
no era tan usual Entonces el hecho de él
ser admirado en todo el mundo es una
muestra de una superación muy importante
me gustaría también recordar que cuando
recientemente murió a Maradona se habló
mucho de Quién sería el Astro más
llorado que provocaría más conmoción si
El Dios del fútbol Maradona o el rey del
fútbol Pelé durante todo el mundial fui
preguntando en las calles a las personas
a los jóvenes y muchos me comentaron
sentimos por una grandísima admiración
pero no hemos vivido sus partidos
históricos porque no nadie de nosotros
había nacido y el hecho de que Pelé haya
estado tanto tiempo enfermo de alguna
forma ha preparado a los brasileños para
esa pérdida en el caso de Maradona por
ejemplo él murió con 60 años de forma
prematura con sospechas de fallo médico
yo que crecí en Nápoles y que vi como el
Astro llegó a crear una verdadera
devoción entre los napolitanos Yo diría
que Pelé sigue siendo el rey del fútbol
pero en más una admiración como se puede
tener para un personaje histórico al que
se tiene cariño pero no hay aquella
memoria contemporánea de partidos que se
vivieron a flor de piel como ha pasado
por ejemplo con su gran rival en el
protagonismo mundial que ha sido
Maradona
Valeria Pelé no solamente fue el mejor
futbolista del mundo también fue
empresario fue artista
cinematográfico uno de los símbolos de
Brasil pero en su momento también en la
década de los 90 fue ministro del
deporte que recordamos sobre esa época
de de Pelé O cuál fue su gestión en ese
momento
él fue ministro de deporte y fue una un
periodo también que es destacado en su
biografía sin embargo por lo que más se
recuerda como jugador y repito en Brasil
hay un fenómeno que yo creo que no se
comprende muy bien fuera del país y es
que una gran parte de la población que
sufrió durante una dictadura que fue
Sangrienta que no fue tan blanda Como
algunos creen tienen cierto recelo por
esta figura porque creen que él siempre
estuvo muy alineado con el régimen Es
verdad que él fue ministro ya en una
época de redemocratización pero era una
época en que todavía estaba muy fresca
la memoria tanto de la represión como de
la tortura de esta dictadura de este
régimen militar también hay que recordar
que la idea de que una persona con mucha
trascendencia sea un deportista sea un
cantante fueron famoso puede usar su
poder para posicionarse políticamente es
relativamente reciente en su época no se
esperaba eso pero repito hay una gran
parte de la población que destaca esto a
pesar obviamente de reconocer de
admirarlo y de recordar que fue un
personaje completamente poliédrico y que
ha hecho historia en varios sentidos en
Brasil